[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Klaus Kleber
guten Abend am 1 November vor einem Jahr
war das ein Datum dass man damals so
schnell wie möglich vergessen wollte der
Vorabend zu Tag eins eines weiteren
shutdowns man durfte hoffen dem letzten
shutdown bis dann bald die Impfung kommt
treffen galt dann nur noch mit einem
anderen Hausstand als legal Kino Theater
Gastro und jedes öffentliche
Unterhaltungsprogramm waren geschlossen
kaum jemand hat damals geglaubt und erst
recht niemand verkündet dass diese
Pandemie ein ganzes Jahr später heute
noch immer nicht vorbei sein würde und
trotzdem ist es jetzt so die Kennzahlen
die doch gerade erst noch harmlos
aussahen galoppieren wieder los klar
damals gab es noch keine Impfung aber
das Virus war auch noch lange nicht mit
der Dauer der Delta Variante unterwegs
die Inzidenz die den Lockdown
unumgänglich machte war damals auf 115
an der Marke sind wir jetzt schon wieder
vorbei Benjamin dialowski
154,8 das ist der Wert der sieben Tage
Inzidenz von heute sie steigt seit
Wochen ähnliches Bild auf den
Intensivstationen dort liegen jetzt
wieder mehr als 2000 kobit-patientinnen
und so geht es weiter Beispiel alten und
Pflegeheime in diesen besonders
verletzlichen Bereichen stieg die Zahl
der kobit Ausbrüche von 78 vergangene
Woche auf 122 jetzt auch an den Schulen
gehen die Zahlen hoch lagen weit über
dem Wert von vergangenen Jahr
kurzfristige Entspannung brachten nur
die Herbstferien also heute alles noch
schlimmer als letzten November
wir haben eine ganz andere Situation
weil wir 55,5 Millionen geimpfte
Menschen haben so dass wir jetzt durch
die Kontakte die wir ermöglichen einen
soziales und öffentliches Leben haben
das völlig anders aussieht als vor einem
Jahr als wir diese steigenden Zahlen
hatten und völlig klar war dass wir
keinen Schutz haben weil es keine
Impfung gab also ist die Impfung ein
ganz großer Unterschied zur Situation
damals gleichwohl sie sehen wir das wenn
man trotzdem Kontakte jetzt ermöglicht
immer noch zu viele Menschen leider
nicht geimpft sind und dadurch gibt man
den Virus sozusagen die Chance sich dann
doch noch weiter auszubreiten und
dadurch entstehen hohe Zahlen das
nächste große Thema die impfdurchbrüche
also Erkrankungen bei Menschen obwohl
sie geimpft sind auf deutschen
Krankenstationen sind zurzeit 32% der
kobit-patienten geimpfte von den
Intensivstationen sind es 25 Prozent bei
den über 60-Jährigen sind diese Zahlen
sogar noch höher wie kann das sein
bei den Geimpften hat der im Mundschutz
nicht ganz verhindern können dass Sie
sich anstecken und auch die nachfolgende
Immunantwort war zu langsam um wirklich
einen schweren Verlauf zu verhindern es
ist aber wichtig zu betonen dass es 250
Menschen auf Intensiv von 55 Millionen
geimpften Menschen sind das zeigt
vielleicht noch mal die Relation dessen
wie gut der Impfschutz generell ist
tatsächlich ist das Impfen wohl immer
noch der beste Schutz das RKI hat
berechnet dass für geimpfte jüngere der
Schutz vor schwerer kovid-erkrankungen
90% betrage 85 Prozent für über
60-Jährige und vor einer Behandlung die
so schwer ist dass man auf die
Intensivstation muss betrage der Schutz
sogar 94% bzw 91% für ältere
die Schlussfolgerung ist sonnenklar wir
müssen die Menschen ab 70 Jahren wie es
von der STIKO empfohlen wurde jetzt
motivieren sich eine Auffrischimpfung zu
holen damit sie den Impfschutz
verbessern denn das sind die Gruppen die
das höchste Risiko haben sich doch noch
anzustecken obwohl sie schon geimpft
waren Deutschland am 1 November vor
einem Jahr und heute irgendwie immer
noch im Griff von Corona
damit wir gemeinsam Weihnachten feiern
können mit dieser Aussicht hat die
Kanzlerin vor einem Jahr den Shutdown
begründet nach all der Erfahrung nach
dem dramatischen Fortschritt der
schnellen Impfung sollte man meinen dass
die politische und fachlich
Verantwortlichen jetzt mit einer
gewissen Ruhe in das öffentlich
hoffentlich letzte Aufräumen der
Pandemie gehen das ist aber absolut
nicht so berichtet Heikes
es war eine politische Entscheidung vor
vier Wochen die Impfzentren fast
flächendeckend in Deutschland zu
schließen zu gering die Nachfrage zu
teuer im Vergleich zu den Hausärzten für
möglichst schnelle boosterimpfungen am
besten für alle plädierte am Wochenende
der geschäftsführende
Gesundheitsminister Jens Spahn und
erntete heftige Kritik von Hausärzten
sie fürchten eine Überlastung pünktlich
zum Ärztetag heute nun ein neuer
Vorschlag von Spahn wie wäre es wenn wir
die Impfzentren für trittimpfungen
wieder öffneten und siehe da schon kehrt
an dieser Front zumindest Ruhe ein im
Zentrum haben uns entlastet und würden
uns jetzt auch weiterhin absolut
entlasten für eben die alten Patienten
in den Altenheimen aber auch für
Patientinnen und Patienten die Arbeiten
die wir in unserer regelsprechstunde
schlecht versorgen können irritiert
zeigt sich jetzt allerdings nicht nur
die Gesundheitsministerin aus
Niedersachsen über den neuen
unabgestimmten Vorschlag spahns-zitat es
war schließlich der Minister der die
Finanzierung der Impfzentren und die
Belieferung der Länder mit Impfstoff zum
30 September eingestellt hat
das Hin und Her in der Pandemie die
stockende Impfquote und steigende Zahlen
auf den Intensivstationen heute schlug
sachsenalarm vor einem Jahr lagen ihre
Infektionszahlen ohne Impfstoff deutlich
niedriger als jetzt mit Impfstoff aber
weniger Maßnahmen keinem shutdown und
der hochansteckenden delta-variante dann
ist eben auch zu verzeichnen dass bei
der Inzidenz der ungeimpften ja eine
Inzidenz von 560 haben und bei den
Geimpften von 59 das ist ein Verhältnis
von 1 zu 10 das heißt so ein und ein
eingeimpfter kommt auf zehn ungeimpfte
der Moment das Virus weitergibt jetzt
recht sich das kaum noch kostenfrei
getestet wird auch dass die Idee von
Jens Spahn viele Zentren haben
geschlossen ungeimpfte müssen selbst
zahlen Ergebnis eine hohe Dunkelziffer
an infizierten und keinen Plan für die
vierte Welle
wir wollten weiter sein um diese Zeit
Professor Thomas Mertens ist der
Vorsitzende der Ständigen Impfkommission
das ist übrigens ein unbezahltes
Ehrenamt seinen Lebensunterhalt verdient
er mit Forschung und Lehre in Ulm wo wir
ihn erreichen guten Abend Professor
Mertens
und Namen der Kleber man merkt doch mit
einigen Schrecken dass die Impfung ein
doch nicht so davor Schutz dass man
andere Menschen infiziert und auch die
Zahl der geimpften die infiziert sind
erschreckt ein sind da falscher
Erwartungen geweckt worden
also eigentlich nicht die Frau Kollegin
falk hat das ja gerade schon mal erklärt
es ist ja so dass es eine Problem der
großen Zahlen ist wir wussten ja schon
von den Zulassungsstudien dass einige
von 100 geimpften eben nicht geschützt
sein würden und da jetzt sehr viele
geimpfte da sind und sehr viel Virus
kursiert summiert sich diese Zahl auf
also eigentlich ist es keine
Überraschung in dem Sinne sondern es ist
das was man von auskenntnis der Zahlen
erwarten konnte nun war ja in letzter
Zeit auch aufgetaucht dass wesentlich
mehr Menschen wahrscheinlich geimpft und
durchgeimpft sind als man zunächst
vermutet hatte 5% etwa mehr als erwartet
und mit diesem Punkt hatte man irgendwie
das Gefühl wäre das Virus unter
Kontrolle trotzdem galoppieren jetzt die
Infektionszahlen wieder los wie kann das
sein
nun sie haben zu Recht gesagt dass das
der Schutz der Impfung sich vor allen
Dingen bezieht auf den Schutz vor
schwerer Erkrankung und da und das haben
sie auch richtig gezeigt funktioniert
diese Schutzwirkung ja sehr gut etwas
weniger gut funktioniert die
Schutzwirkung vor Infektionen also
Infektionen mit dem Virus und diese
Menschen die infiziert sind obwohl sie
nicht schwer erkranken können das Virus
auch weitergeben nicht so gut wie
ungeimpfte aber doch auch weitergeben
und außerdem muss man sagen dass wir vor
allen Dingen in der Gruppe der
19/18 bis 59-Jährigen einfach mit 72
Prozent etwa an Impfquote und sehr
unterschiedlichen verschiedenen
Bundesländern wo das ja bis fast 60
Prozent teilweise runter geht das ist
einfach zu wenig da hätte man mehr
Impfung erreichen müssen wenn das so ist
dass die Gesundheit insgesamt in
Deutschland und der Gang der Pandemie
von mehr Lungen abhängt ist es denn dann
wirklich auf Dauer richtig dass diese
Entscheidung Einzelnen überlassen bleibt
jeder für sich entscheidet manchmal nach
Wissensstand manchmal nach Laune
manchmal nach Überzeugung und nicht
immer in voller Kenntnis der
wissenschaftlichen Zusammenhänge die Sie
zum Beispiel erklären
das ist sicher ein Problem was Sie
ansprechen man muss aber fairerweise
sagen dass das kein wissenschaftliches
Problem ist sondern das ist etwas was
politisch entschieden werden muss das
ist ganz klar eine Frage der politischen
Entscheidung ob man für bestimmte
Berufsgruppen oder ein sogenannten
Impfzwang einführen möchte und da muss
man natürlich verschiedene Aspekte
berücksichtigen das ganz klar auch die
Gegenreaktion aber noch mal es ist eine
politische Entscheidung unter diese
Entscheidung müsste in der Politik
getroffen werden und was ist ihr
wissenschaftlicher Rat an die Politiker
nun mein wissenschaftlicher Rat ist dass
es in der Tat sehr wichtig ist dass
viele Menschen geimpft werden und wenn
ich es völlig emotionslos sehe dann ist
es auch nicht so wichtig auf welchem
Wege das geschieht aber ich muss es noch
mal sagen es ist eine Entscheidung die
wir als Volksgemeinschaft letztendlich
über unsere gewählten Volksvertreter
treffen müssen nun ist das politische
Thema das im Moment vordringlich
behandelt wird diese booster-impfung
dieser dritte Schuss sozusagen in den
allermeisten Fällen ist das der goldene
Weg jetzt möglichst viele Menschen
möglichst schnell mit einer dritten
Impfung auszustatten
nun ja es ist zunächst mal sehr wichtig
dass wir die Menschen jetzt zum dritten
Mal impfen die auch das höchste Risiko
haben eine schwere Erkrankung zu
erleiden wenn sie sich denn wieder
infizieren und das sind eben die alten
Menschen über 70 und es sind die
Menschen die einen gestörtes Immunsystem
haben die also nicht normal
immunologisch reagieren können und es
sind letztlich auch die Menschen mit
bestimmten Vorerkrankungen und das ist
glaube ich
unpraktikabel zu verlangen dass man
jetzt das die gesamte Bevölkerung auf
einen Schlag eine dritte Impfung
mit einigen Erfolg
nein ja gut aber es gibt viele Dinge die
in Israel etwas anders sind das fängt
zum Beispiel auch damit an dass sie die
beiden Impfungen im Abstand von 21 Tagen
gegeben hat also das sind genau die
Dinge die wir jetzt im Augenblick sehr
intensiv prüfen und zwar die Frage
inwieweit wir durch eine Impfung sehr
vieler Menschen unabhängig vom Alter und
Risiko tatsächlich die Transmission also
Übertragung des Virus
vermindern können und diese Frage
beschäftigt uns auch als STIKO im
Augenblick sehr wir arbeiten übrigens
auch zusammen mit ausländischen
Wissenschaftlern in dieser Frage und wir
müssen sehen was von diesen
Erkenntnissen tatsächlich auf
Deutschland übertragbar ist kommt aber
hinzu dass natürlich eine dritte Impfung
nur für die in Frage kommt die die
ersten beiden schon erhalten haben und
damit sind wir wieder beim Thema der
Grundimmunisierung letzte Frage und das
kann eine ganz kurze Antwort sein wann
ist das Ding hier vorbei
als Virus ist es nicht vorbei jedenfalls
nicht in den nächsten vielen
Generationen nun Pandemie ist eine
Definitionssache letztendlich in der man
wird im nächsten Jahr das sicher dann
irgendwann als weltweit in demisches
Virus bezeichnen können das ändert zwar
nichts am Sachverhalt aber es ändert
zumindest die Terminologie Dankeschön
Professor Mertens für Ihren Rat und
einen guten Namen bitteschön und die
Nachrichten müssen mit dem Thema Corona
weitergehen
von heute an gilt in Österreich die drei
g-regel am Arbeitsplatz für die
Beschäftigten die Kontakte nicht
ausschließen können Arbeitgeber sind
verpflichtet zu kontrollieren bei
Verstößen drohen ihnen hohe Strafen von
bis zu 3.600 Euro die Regierung in Wien
erhofft sich von der Verschärfung dass
sich wieder mehr Menschen impfen lassen
in Österreich liegt die Impfquote bei
63%
in der CDU wird über das Wahlverfahren
für die Nachfolge von Parteichef Armin
Laschet beraten noch gibt es keine
offizielle Bewerbung auf einer Klausur
der nordrhein-westfälischen CDU
Landesgruppe im Bundestag wurde die
Wahlniederlage analysiert im Beisein
aller möglichen Kandidaten für den
Parteivorsitz morgen werden Präsidium
und Bundesvorstand über die Umsetzung
einer Mitgliederbefragung beraten wie
von den cdu-kreisvorsitzenden mit großer
Mehrheit gefordert
im Oktober hat die Bundespolizei fast
5.300 Menschen aufgegriffen die über
Belarus und Polen
illegal nach Deutschland eingereist sind
allein am Wochenende wurden an der
Grenze zu Polen auf deutschem Gebiet 597
unerlaubt eingereistet mit
belarussischen Visa oder
einreisestempeln festgestellt im
Frühjahr hatte Belarus Machthaber
Lukaschenko als Reaktion auf
EU-Sanktionen erklärt er werde Migranten
in Richtung EU nicht aufhalten
und damit zum langfristig wohl
wichtigsten Thema dieser Tage der
Klimakonferenz in Glasgow wenn die
scheitert dann wird man sich wenigstens
an eine große Rede erinnern heute eine
Rede die eine letzte Chance markierte
gehalten nicht von einem Mann der Macht
sondern einem Mann des Wissens Sir David
attenboro 95 Jahre der alte Meister der
Natur und Tierfilme war gerufen worden
den mächtigen ins Gewissen zu reden mit
Fakten mit seiner ganzen Autorität
führte er der Konferenz vor Augen dass
die Menschheitsgeschichte alles wovon
unser Lebensstil und unsere leben heute
abhängen das Ergebnis einer Gnade der
Natur war über 10.000 Jahre stabil
niedrige CO2-Werte in der Atmosphäre die
die Naturgewalten in Schranken hielten
und diese Balance zerstören wir
diese Entwicklung müssen sie verhindern
mit ihren Entscheidungen flehte atemboro
das erwartet die Welt dafür sind sie
hier is why the world is looking to you
and why you
david hat die Latte damit nur so hoch
gelegt wie sie liegen muss was
buchstäblich tatsächlich geschah
berichtet Diana zimmermann
für die Anreise war sie zu schwach aber
ganz durfte sie nicht fehlen bei der
Klimakonferenz und dem prächtigen
Abendempfang im Calvin Grove Museum per
Videobotschaft meldete sich die Queen
die staatenführer müssten nun handeln
auf große benefits natürlich werden
nicht alle hier die Vorteile dieser
Handlungen genießen dürfen keiner von
uns wird ewig leben aber wir tun dies
nicht für uns sondern für unsere Kinder
und Kindeskinder und diejenigen die auf
sie folgen werden
Tags im Konferenzzentrum machten die 120
Staats- und Regierungschefs schon
besorgte Gesichter sie sahen Szenen wie
aus einem Katastrophenfilm und doch war
es nur das was der Klimawandel schon
anrichtet
heute ist die Erde 1,1 Grad wärmer als
vor der Industrialisierung selbst wenn
alle hier anwesenden ihre Versprechungen
einhielten Stiege die Temperatur weit
höher als um die noch erträglichen 1,5
Grad
Gastgeber Boris Johnson will ein Happy
End für die Welt und den Gipfel
humanity die Menschheit hat beim
Klimawandel lange auf Zeit gespielt
jetzt ist es auf dieser Uhr eine Minute
vor zwölf und wir müssen handeln
die ganze Welt ist ein Glasgow viele mit
erschreckenden berichten inständigen
bitten wütenden Plädoyers
wenn Sie heute hier sind wissen Sie was
der Klimawandel uns an Tod sie brauchen
weder meinen Schmerz noch meine Tränen
um zu wissen dass wir in einer Krise
sind
Joe Biden entschuldigte sich für den
Stillstand in der amerikanischen
Klimapolitik unter seinem Vorgänger und
versprach den Ausstieg aus der Kohle zu
beschleunigen mehr Geld für den
Klimaschutz in ärmeren Ländern zu zahlen
bilaterale Projekte zu fördern die USA
wollen 2050 CO2-neutral sein für Angela
Merkel war es der letzte Klimagipfel
ihren ersten hatte sie vor 25 Jahren
wir wissen dass insbesondere Weise die
Industrieländer Verantwortung tragen und
das betrifft natürlich auch die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
deshalb haben wir unsere Klimaziele noch
einmal verschärft wir wollen bis 2045
klimaneutral sein trotzdem sehen junge
UmweltschützerInnen eine kritische
Bilanz wenn man auf die letzten
zierungen zurückblickt in der einfach
wenig passiert ist in Deutschland im
Gegenteil der erneuerbar der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren ist zurückgegangen und die
Emissionen sind gestiegen es kann man
sie einfach nicht mehr Klimakanzlerin
nennen doch die eigentlichen
Verhandlungen beginnen jetzt erst zwölf
Tage in denen viele Menschen mit viel
Engagement der versorgen wollen dass am
Ende doch mehr als nur heiße Luft
rauskommt so mancher Staatschef
allerdings gibt sich nicht mal die Mühe
guten Willen auch nur zu demonstrieren
weder Wladimir Putin noch hidin Ping
sind nach Glasgow gekommen
ein Grund weshalb diese Klima Diplomatie
so frustrierend wirkt liegt darin dass
es so einfach ist immer erstmal auf die
anderen zu zeigen die doch vorangehen
sollten Deutschlands Beitrag zur
globalen Erwärmung sind schließlich nur
ein paar wenige Prozent ganz Europa
zusammengenommen ist wahrscheinlich
verantwortlich für gerade mal sieben
halb die USA schlimmste pro
kopfverbraucher überhaupt liefern
doppelt so viel und trotzdem sind das
auch nur 15 Prozent der unbestreitbar
schlimmste Verschmutzer ist China mit
noch mal doppelt so viel fast 30 Prozent
da geht es also wirklich zur Sache china
hat aber auch fast ein Fünftel der
Weltbevölkerung zu ernähren und in
großen Teilen des Landes die
industrielle Revolution noch nachzuholen
mit der wir das Klima längst belastet
haben warum dann wir sagen sie auch im
Peking Stefanie Schöneborn ist unsere
Korrespondentin dort
Windkraftanlagen soweit das Auge reicht
das ist das was uns bei einer staatlich
organisierten presse-tour in Ostchina
gezeigt wird tatsächlich gibt es kein
Land weltweit das so viel Geld für
regenerative Energien ausgibt bis 2030
soll 25 Prozent des Stromverbrauchs
Chinas aus nicht fossilen Quellen
stammen einige testgemeinden sollen
klimaneutral werden
wir versuchen einige Gemeinden zu bauen
die CO2-arm bzw CO2-neutral sind hier
soll nur erneuerbare Energie genutzt
werden und es soll ein rein grünes
Energienetz aufgebaut werden
die Realität sieht derzeit anders aus 60
Prozent der Energieversorgung kommt aus
der Kohle kein Land pumpt derzeit mehr
CO2 in die Luft als China kein Land hat
im letzten Jahr so viele Kohlekraftwerke
in Betrieb genommen das sind 70 Prozent
aller Inbetriebnahme weltweit und
weitere 368 kohlekraftwerke sind im
Planung Kritik von einem unabhängigen
internationalen thinktec
es ist klar dass China nicht wirklich
grün ist China ist der bei weitem größte
kohleverbraucher der Welt verbraucht die
Hälfte der weltweiten Kohle und das bei
nur einem Sechstel der Weltbevölkerung
im chinesischen Staatsfernsehen wird
chijin-pinks Energiemix mit hübschen
Bildern propagiert er verspricht eine
emissionsfreie Zukunft bis 2016 wie
China klimaneutral sein doch bis 2030
wird China seinen CO2-Ausstoß erstmal in
die Höhe treiben müssen um den
steigenden Energiebedarf für die
Wirtschaft zu sichern so die offizielle
Begründung experten erwarten klare
Signale seitens der EU
es muss eine klare Botschaft geben die
Emissionen müssen schneller ihren
Höhepunkt erreichen dass es wichtig wir
können nicht zulassen dass die
Emissionen aus China noch fast zehn
Jahre lang steigen
und dann hat China noch ein Problem die
privaten Haushalte das chinesische Netz
ist voll mit Geschichten von Menschen
die nicht wissen wie sie über den Winter
kommen sollen die Gaspreise können viele
nicht zahlen auch Kohle ist zu teuer
mittlerweile doppelt so hoch wie im Jahr
zuvor doch werden die meisten auch in
diesem Winter wohl mit Kohle Heizen und
Kochen und das wird dann wieder für
einen Großteil der winterlichen
smog-tagesorgen
und passend dazu kam heute die Meldung
aus China dass das Riesenreich
strategische Reserven an Benzin und
dieselbeständen auflöst das höhere
Angebot auf dem Weltmarkt führte
kurzfristig zu einer leichten
Entspannung der hohen Sprit und
Energiepreise was aber steckt dahinter
Frank bedmann auch vor dem Hintergrund
dass auch Chinas Wirtschaft sich gegen
die pandemiebedingte Krise stimmen muss
ja da kommt gerade viel zusammen die
zweitgrößte Volkswirtschaft China mit
einem Rekordwachstum zu Jahresbeginn die
Pandemie bereits hinter sich gelassen zu
haben doch inzwischen hat der rote
Drachen ganz schön zu kämpfen da ist
nicht nur Corona da sind die Turbulenzen
am Immobilienmarkt da ist der
Materialmangel und die sich häufenden
Stromausfälle im Oktober deuteten
zuletzt gleich zwei Stimmungsindikatoren
an einer für eher kleine und mittlere
Betriebe der andere für die großen
staatlich dominierten Industriekonzerne
das von China in den kommenden Monaten
wohl nur eine leichte Wachstumsdynamik
ausgehen wird das PE nun Teile seiner
Vorratslager auflöst und Öl und Diesel
auf dem Markt schmeißt darf als Reaktion
auf die schlechte Stimmung im Land
gewertet werden langfristig lösen wird
es die derzeitigen Energieprobleme aber
nicht selbst kurzfristig verpuffte der
Effekt schnell nach kurzer Entspannung
steigt der Rohölpreis nämlich bereits
wieder einen Fass der Nordseesorte Brent
kostet inzwischen wieder 84 Dollar 55
und damit 1,2% mehr selbst das mächtige
china hat nicht annähernd den Einfluss
auf den Ölpreis wie in die Erdöl
exportierenden Länder haben doch die
opec-plus so macht es den anscheinend
denkt derzeit überhaupt nicht daran den
Weltmarkt zu fluten ja etwas weiter wird
man den Hahn aufdrehen doch Öl wird in
den kommenden Monaten weiter ein knappes
Gut bleibt Frank Widmann vielen Dank
nach dem mutmaßlichen Machtmissbrauch im
Springerkonzern wird die Chefredaktion
der Bild-Zeitung um zwei weitere
JournalistInnen ergänzt in das Team um
den neuen Chefredakteur Johannes Boje
kommen Linner Nickel und Antje
Schippmann Boje folgte vor kurzem auf
den langjährigen bildchefredakteur
Julian Reichelt dem vorgeworfen wird
seine Macht vor allem gegenüber jungen
KollegInnen missbraucht und Privates und
Berufliches nicht klar getrennt zu haben
die bekannte Kolumnistin des SPIEGEL
Bettina Gaus ist im Alter von 64 Jahren
nach kurzer schwerer Krankheit gestorben
oft war die fein beobachtende
Journalistin auch zu Gast im ZDF
Morgenmagazin und analysierte die
Presseberichterstattung zu den großen
Themen der Zeit
der letzte Beitrag dieses Journals
schaut in wunderbaren Bildern einem Mann
beim Scheitern zu einem Mann der glauben
durfte sein Leben im Griff zu haben und
das einer Frau dass das schiefgehen muss
ist in der Gestalt dieser Frau und der
Kunst ihrer Darstellerin unwiderstehlich
angelegt Lea sedu einer Meisterin
allergenes die gerade auch neben Bill
Murray und James Bond an die Wand spielt
diese Saison markiert ihren Aufstieg zum
Weltstar sagt Sabine Schulz
mag das Meer noch so stürmisch sein
Kapitän Jakob Stöhr verliert nie die
Kontrolle
aber dann lässt er sich auf eine
verrückte Wetter ein
[Musik]
ich will heiraten habe ich beschlossen
hast du keine Angst ich könnte zum
Beispiel die erste Frau heiraten die zur
Tür hereinkommt
die Geschichte meiner Frau ein frischer
Blick auf einen Klassiker der
Weltliteratur ein Sittenbild vom Europa
der 1920er Jahre doch auch einer moderne
Version des Machtgefüges zwischen Mann
und Frau
denn Lissy die junge Französin
hinreißend gespielt von Lea Seydou ist
im Frauenbild ihrer Zeit weit voraus
selbst bestimmt scharfsinnig ihrem
Partner ebenbürtig wenn nicht überlegen
und das ausgerechnet beim seemannspoker
es wäre schön wenn das wirklich
funktionieren würde ja das wäre es
es ist der Beginn einer großen
dramatischen Liebe
zwischen Leidenschaft Eifersucht und
Misstrauen erzählt ausschließlich aus
der Sicht und Erinnerung des stoisch
verschlossenen Mannes und das hat einen
Grund
[Musik]
ich wollte durch die Erfahrung des
Kapitäns all den Männern die Hand
reichen die in alten Mustern gefangen
sind die umdenken und das Miteinander
völlig neu erlernen müssen seit dem
Kindergarten hat man ihnen eingebläut
dass sie loser sind wenn sie nicht alles
unter Kontrolle haben ihr Leben und das
ihrer Frauen
immer wieder ist Stör für Monate auf
hoher See Lissy scheint das nicht zu
stören sie geht auf im
gesellschaftlichen Leben der Pariser
Salons
ist sie im untreu
ich würde einfach gern wissen was Sie
den ganzen Tag tut manchmal weiß man es
besser nicht ein Umzug nach Hamburg soll
in die Kontrolle über seine Frau
erleichtern doch sie bleibt rätselhaft
für ihn und undurchschaubar
da ist
es gibt immer eine Seite an einem
anderen Menschen die uns fremd bleibt
die wir nicht verstehen und nicht
kontrollieren können das müssen wir
akzeptieren mehr noch wir müssen es
schätzen sogar bewundern denn sonst
vergiften wir die Beziehung und unser
Leben
Szenen eine vergifteten Ehe aber das ist
noch lange nicht das Ende der Film lässt
sich dafür fast drei Stunden Zeit doch
er belohnt mit magischen kinobildern wie
Gemälde
mit Blicken die stärker sind als Worte
ein kunstvoller ein sehenswerter Film
mit großartigen Darstellern
ich bleibe bei dir gut wenn du meinst
tja seit me too ist jede Frauengestalt
in Hollywood im Spiegel dieser die
Zeiten wenden denn Enthüllungen zu sehen
und zu verstehen was von diesem Abend an
Zeit bleibt wird man das ZDF diesen
Skandal und seine Wirkung in Spielfilm
und Dokumentation es lohnt sich also
jetzt weder aus noch umzuschalten wir
sagen bis Morgen und einen guten Abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter CO2 also
kohlenstoffdioxid ist wohl das
bekannteste Treibhausgas aber Methan
wirkt 25 mal schädlicher seit Beginn der
Industrialisierung hat sich sein Anteil
der Atmosphäre mehr als verdoppelt
besonders in den vergangenen Jahren ist
der stark angestiegen mehr als die
Hälfte aller Methanemissionen sind vom
Menschen verursacht hauptqualle für das
Gas ist Landwirtschaft es gibt geschätzt
weit über eine Milliarde Rinder und die
stoßen bei ihrer Verdauung Methan aus
und fossile Brennstoffe methanes
Hauptbestandteil von Erdgas es tritt aus
durch Lex in Pipelines bei der Förderung
oder durch aufgegebene Bohrstellen
zusammengefasst rasche Maßnahmen
momentan zu reduzieren könnten laut
Weltklimarat die Erhitzung unseres
Planeten deutlich verlangsamen
so weit so methano zum Klima wir schauen
aufs Wetter und da gibt es im Südosten
viel Regen und auch nach Nordosten hin
das verlagert sich allmählich nach
Südwesten in ebenfalls ist aber nicht so
viel sonst gibt es viele Wolken bei
tiefsten Temperaturen von drei Grad an
den Alpen sonst bei 4 bis 8 Grad und
morgen einem Tagesverlauf da lässt der
Regen im Südosten nach Richtung Bayern
da gibt es ein bisschen Sonnenschein
mehr Regen dann im Osten neue Schauer
ziehen von Westen her auf ansonsten
gibt's dazwischen aber sonnige
Abschnitte bei höchsten Temperaturen von
7 bis 12 Grad die kommenden Tage ja da
gibt es Regen am Mittwoch von Westen her
sonst auch trockene Abschnitte sechs bis
zwölf Grad ab Donnerstag wird es
allerdings deutlich kühler 4 bis 11 Grad
ein schöner Abend